foreign
Betsy is with us in Asheville North
Carolina hi Betsy welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey thanks so much for taking my call
and I'm absolutely going to get a
gazelle card well thank you
I love it how can we help today
um I you've changed my life um but I
think it might be too late for me and I
needed to kind of tell you that
um I I've been more fortunate than a lot
of people I've learned through many
thousands of dollars I've had big chunks
of money from various things uh
inheritances whatever
um and basically I am 66 years old I
sold my business four years ago for two
hundred thousand dollars
and I sold a house I'm now renting very
cheaply and um
I have
about two hundred thousand dollars still
and I'm living on six to seven hundred
dollars a month because I've lived very
cheaply but I wanted to give you the
numbers and and have you laugh at me and
say no you're not going to make it
because my core values are freedom and
Independence
and it petrifies me to think
um that I won't have Financial you know
stability and I'm unable to work because
of a neurological
condition where it can't be upright
spherionophen
so should I just give you the numbers
yeah that's fine sure
okay I invested a hundred thousand
dollars a year ago in a local commercial
lender they do alternative lending to
people that don't go through traditional
Banks and that's a that's a guaranteed
eight percent a year so that 100 000 has
turned into a hundred to eight thousand
I put forty five thousand dollars in the
Vanguard last year when I first found
you guys and it's down to thirty eight
thousand
um of course I'm not selling it but um
that hurts it's basically a wash on what
I made from the other investment
um I have my IRAs are about 17 000 and
my cash is about eight about nineteen
thousand so somewhere between I don't I
don't know the add up of that but
I go through my expenses in my budget
every month and I say okay 600 a month
divided by our 100 let's see eighteen
thousand dollars divided by six hundred
dollars a month oh good I can live 24
more months on that before I have to
tapped into my investments
but am I am I just um living a pipe
dream am I going to be a if I can really
stick to a budget
are you not collecting Social Security
oh that I don't even include that
because that actually paid my rent
it's a wash I get a thousand dollars I
pay a thousand dollars so basically I
spend 600 out of my savings amount six
to seven out of savings
I see okay and my Social Security will
be going up of course but um
you know and you're making 8 000 on one
investment and the other investment
because the Market's down is down right
now
yes okay and tell me again what you put
in Vanguard again
I put 45 000 and I put 15 000 in the uh
what's the one that you have a minimum
of 15 000 like the silver or the yeah
I've got some word for it is in that and
thirty thousand so you only have a
hundred and fifty thousand
no I have almost 200 I have 108 plus the
original 45 right let's call it that
yeah and then in my in my savings I've
got 19. oh I see yeah for your emergency
phone yeah and my IRAs I've got 1700. I
mean 17 000. and I'm trying to see if I
can live on
six to seven hundred dollars a month and
stretch it out until I'm like I'm 66 so
I mean if I don't want to get married
five six or six six
yeah I'll be 67 next month okay all
right well I
yes you're gonna make it and no it's not
a pipe dream and no it's not all come to
an end
um it's the worst possible year to have
this conversation with Vanguard going
the wrong direction which is an unusual
thing uh I don't know exactly what you
put that in but if you're just in a good
growth stock mutual fund it would be
down this year the Market's down yeah
and uh most years it's up it's an
unusual little bad economy that we're in
and
um a lot of reasons for that but that's
not the purpose of this call so um right
and I'm hoping by next year we see a
turnaround yeah because I'm going to go
early vote this afternoon just to make
sure we do but um
but anyway the uh uh
well I'm
can I just insert one more thing sure I
come from a family of such Spenders that
it is
it's really hit me this month that I've
still been spending too much and so now
I'm I'm 600 a month is too much
no I spent 2000 in September oh so
you're not sticking to your budget
I am now but no okay that's why I mean
whatever budget you set you have to put
that into your projections and then if
you don't stick to it you screw up your
projections
right so that that's that's that's the
third variable that you've added now and
yeah I will say you got to do that or
you whatever I mean because I don't care
if you make 50 000 a month and you spend
sixty thousand you still got a pipe
dream right definitely so um that's the
thing so I I would tell you this I want
you to sit down with a smartvester pro
and uh stir this portfolio a little and
see if we can't make it do a little
better over the Long Haul okay I don't
know what that it would do better on the
short haul if you had done what I told
you to do like with the money if you've
done that two years ago you might be
worse off right now than you are right
now because the Market's down and I I'm
62 and
um I'm 100 I don't I'm 100 invested in
the market
I mean and pulled anything out but uh
but but in a little different situation
so yeah I think sitting down with Smart
Vista Pro sticking to your budget you
got you know then lay your projections
out but I think overall you probably can
do better than either one of these
Investments but not a ton
uh and then the third thing I would tell
you is this
had a perfectly normal conversation here
with you for three or four minutes five
minutes so there is some things you can
do even if it's just a few hours a day
or a week even if it's just uh finding
something online that you you know you
sell stuff on eBay whatever it is you're
able to do with the limitations that you
have with the the medical process you're
facing I'm still going to find something
I can do to because here's the thing if
you add a thousand dollars a month to
this
by working uh five hours a week doing
something online you know or or on the
phone or something uh you change this
number you change the situation
dramatically a thousand dollars a month
changes your whole math picture with the
numbers you're giving me because they're
so small
and so I'm gonna think about what you
can do within the limitations I'm not
trying to say you you've been lazy or
something you're certainly not that but
you're very articulate very quick very
uh intelligent on the phone so that
means there's things you can do yeah and
if this year you were able to live off 8
000 you know maybe with compound
interest next year we shoot for nine
thousand and then ten thousand and over
the next 10 years as the money continues
to grow and you continue to live on a
budget we can make this work but right
now it might be tight for this year yeah
yeah but overall is is there hope
there's hope because you're breathing
and there's hope because you're paying
attention it's not too late and if you
pay attention and you keep breathing
then you're there